So praseodymium is a very interesting element.
It’s got a myriad of uses
but perhaps the most interesting one is that
it has been used to enable
us to get within 1/1000th of a degree of Absolute
Zero, which is minus
273 degrees C, which is pretty darn cold.
It was just used in the components which
they were using in the coils to get the temperature
down.
It’s also used in welder’s goggles because
it’s quite good at filtering out
harmful types of light to the human eye, so
you find it’s in the goggle
and it helps the welder be able to see what
he’s doing.
It’s also been used in a silicate which
is being used to lower the speed of
light down to a mere 300 metres per second,
which is still pretty fast but
not very fast compared to the normal speed
of light.